one more
10 all right
let's all
right for simp licity sake let's divide
up uh two different types of engines you
have leverage engin so i' have a fulcrum
here at his elbow and then a lever at
his wrist okay and I push and
pull and it works it generates energy to
overcome resistance either in the shape
of this mass or in the in the his
counter his Marshall counter it works
okay uh that's one one type of engine
I'm going to say that's an external
material engine okay another type of
engine
is uh let's say he has uh momentum and
inertia going this way so you don't lean
or anything just Chico that way there
you go and his arms going forward okay
so his arms going forward go ahead and
I'm going to take it over here utilizing
that energy and inertia and even without
the
elbow you get the same result okay I am
going to for Simplicity sake call that
an energetic engine I am not implying
there's no energy in the fcum lever but
it is not functioning through a fulcrum
lever okay and it's not really
functioning um materially either because
I'm controlling the elbow
by allowing the energy the inertia and
the momentum to go forward I don't need
a fol on the elbow okay
so as he's going forward I could put
that on the elbow but I'm not cranking
it so like for example uh EO he pushes
EO Ur looks like that too but I'm not
shoving that down you can have where
you're here and you're just doing fulam
lever stuff okay
let's go to ad nag so let's have you be
over here facing the other way come over
here it's right
there and you're going to do the
kazushi you can use basically a
mechanical fulum lever engine here I
grab at the collar okay that's my lever
and then his feet is the f rub and so I
pull and
turn same do this way I'm using his feet
and I pull and
turn the placement on the collar is not
relevant you could do the same thing
pull and
turn if you're up on the neck it's not
relevant whether you're on the jaw
you're on the jaw that doesn't matter
pull and turn
those are all material fulum lever
engines face that way
again an energetic engine would be I
want you just to slowly travel that way
and shico let me see do it first slowly
travel that way and she
okay is I hold he slowly
goes
and because he's going that
way eventually his feet move forward of
his head and he falls the same way so in
the fulcrum engine lever his feet stayed
still because that's my fulcrum and I
pulled his head this way in the
energetic engine I had his feet go
forward and I kept his head
still in this engine there's some
benefits to this okay in this fulcrum
lever engine even though you generate
theoretically a mechanical advantage
relevant to you that Advantage might not
be strong enough to pull someone over
just like you might have too short a
lever to move X size of Boulder if
you're trying to pry it okay so if he's
really strong he's going that way and
I'm he's moving me now not the other way
around
okay you will be more efficient if you
just hold the head still cuz I'm not
trying to move the head I hold the head
still and then he moves so I'm only
moving a quarter a corner of it it'll
take
less output from me okay second
advantage or or let's say second
disadvantage of these pulling techniques
is that nothing actually turns the
guy I never expose the back what happens
his choreography kicks in and he turns
himself but if I if he's just there and
I pull back he he would just rock like
that and I want to expose the back and E
nugget if we're doing any I want to
expose the back I don't want to hide the
back
so now what I'm going to
do go slow he's going to go forward and
I'll tell you when to stop there I
already got a slight turn on him he's
not pointing exactly straight camera
moves wherever you can see that little
deviation okay stay right
there and then I would move again in my
own ASI VY you see and he would keep
moving forward and it got more you see
you fell a little past it there you go
and I would turn
again and he would move forward
more and you get more rotation do you
see and you would turn again and he'd be
going forward more and then you got the
full
rotation
okay
so we'll go
here face me and we doing katori I'm
bring him
around I come around not to pull him but
just to stop the head as he's going
forward and keep my rotation going and
then he
falls it does not matter if you're right
on close with your anchor because you're
not shoving him down you're just holding
it and continually turning keep going
forward as he goes so it does not
matter if your arm is
anchored or if it's long he keeps going
doesn't
matter in terms of the
kazushi it may matter in terms of
whether you stayed in his back
or not go
forward see everything in the back we'll
do the arm
long I usually take one more ten con to
stay in the back as opposed to
[Music]
here
one more
10 all right
let's all right let's try that kazushi
the second one the energetic engine not
the material
external fulam lever engine let's go
okay so that was a explanation of the
engine that you're using and the engine
you're not using now you start asking
and answering well how did you get the
engine in place okay um well the first
thing is it has to be done
internally so the first internal engine
that you have let's face the other way
cuz the camera's on the other side face
that way okay the first one is your
adhesion here so you're not grabbing it
you're not doing a buul and mind meld
you're not fish hooking him you're not
grabbing the collar okay you're just
here this is your adhesion and you are
matching his young energy when you match
his y energy which is generated here in
this case uh the grav gravitational pull
on his Mass uh his inertia and momentum
which is going straight uh so that means
laterally there's a Yang energy stopping
the lateral there and I I have to match
the Yang energy and when I match the Y
keep your don't don't be limpy okay keep
the the matches y energy and then what
happens iy happens and then this gets
stuck so if I'm loose and he goes
forward he just slips off and if I'm
hard like this he slips off again too
but if I'm just matching his you get you
feel it there's a little stuckness I
open my fingers so you could see it it's
energetic it's not anatomical so
energetic he goes and I'm stuck on that
hand so you want you need that to do
what I'm
doing once you have
that because you have inertia and
momentum working
against his
falling the Yang value goes
up which means at the I adhesion there's
a lot of energy there's way more
friction than even here just standing
still where he tries to go that's why
it's easier to get adhesion IE adhesion
at more intense levels and it requires
more skill at softer levels which it's
the inverse of what most people think is
like it gets easier to do the internal
at the higher energetic levels okay so
you have to start with that adhesion but
as he continues to go forward your
adhesion now starts to work in contrast
to the outward pulling energy so because
you're taking on a curve your
centrifugal energy is your y energy and
your adhesion is your centripetal energy
and you're matching that at a higher
Yang value got it everyone with me so as
he starts to go forward it increases you
feel how he got more sticky on you as as
I trying to turn him in with this engine
as he tries to go forward see how it bit
into your skin more and he goes and the
more I take it on a turn you feel how it
got tighter you see that you feel that
okay that's what you have to do go
back you want that and so that means
that you cannot stop
him so you can't go here he's
stopped because now all you have is that
lower ID value you don't want that you
want to do it when he's moving which is
also which is also what is martially
viable
that UK who stopped is the adversary who
countered he has to keep moving so I'm
moving him and I'm moving him and he
should be now in that
curve not here stop and then I go this
is now something
different move him move him and the
curve he
goes
okay to do
this you have to
reconcile the cardinal direction
opposition so right now I'm at 12 Key's
at
6:00 you never this is part of your
kihon waza training you never keep 126
opposition and then do your Technique
it's not going to
work you're given for the prescription a
126 opposition but part of your training
is that you're going to undo
it so watch where I em me we already
said when I don't em me
here that's now contrary energy to
him so I'm going to take him on a
curve and then I move inside that Circle
P
here for Simplicity sake we'll keep him
still your Ed me is at the
90 behind
him not at the 90 antagonist s to his
Direction keep it moving this
way all right let's try it